on is there ever a legitimate use for
Human Rights Tribunal or counsel and if
you could comment also going forward in
the fight over gender expression gender
identity
how do people combat or win that fight
in front of Human Rights courts and
tribunals and yeah believe it that oh no
there's no excuse for them there that
that's why they're called social justice
tribunals in Ontario like that's what
they're called and so look it up
yourself and that's what they are so we
had a court system that worked perfectly
well which doesn't mean it worked very
well but it means it works better than
any alternative anyone has ever be able
to think up and the Human Rights
Tribunal can suspend nor normal
jurisprudential standards they use
preponderance of evidence they don't
assume individual innocence and they can
change the rules as they see fit
and so those bloody things are
pathological to the core and they're
their mouthpieces of the postmodernist
neo-marxists as far as I'm concerned and
they're setting up a parallel law system
and they're also doing that they're also
and this is this is the wind government
they're also forcing the universities to
adopt particular definitions of sexual
harassment that make every let's call it
complicated interchange between human
beings into a act of violence not that
I'm trying to justify stupidity or
oppression but we're all stupid and
we're all oppressors until the
probability that we'll make some sort of
dopey sexual errors a hundred percent
and now that's become grounds for you
know accusations of rape and they're
forcing the universities and ecologists
to become parallel legal systems as well
and that's all very well advanced it's
already been adopted at the U of T if
there's a consequence of direct
legislation and you better look out
because even if the people who are
running those institutions right now are
reasonable which they're not they will
absolutely be replaced by people who
exactly want that kind of power
and will absolutely use it so no those
things should be abolished we have a
legal system you know the Law Society
now I may not have this exactly right
but I've got it mostly right the Law
Society in Ontario has already decided
that lawyers are racists they're going
to force them to undergo unconscious
bias training and they've come to and
they're agreeing by the way they've
already come to the conclusion that
because the legal profession does not
have the precise representation that you
would expect if you did a demographic
analysis of the population according to
the terms defined by the social justice
warriors that it's racist and that
they're racist and that they need to be
trained unconscious first it's like so
go ahead lawyers like line up man
admit your guilt you're done and you
deserve it too
so you